Welcome back everyone this is my full marvel
What If video for Ultron with the infinity
gauntlet press F to pay respects to the multiverse
I know you have a bunch of questions about
what happened here in this end credit scene.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes there
still two episodes left in season one, and
we will be getting What If season 2.
And they will be incorporating the plot of
the new marvel phase 4 movies and characters.
During those two obviously careful for spoilers
if you have not seen episode seven yet.
Because this is meant to set up what's happening
in the finale.
Like a big two-part finale.
Although another a lot of questions about
a missing episode.
They did say that there was one episode of
that the push to season to just because of
all the virus related production delays that
have affected the marvel movies and the marvel
Disney plus series at the end of this episode
in this alternate universe party Thor.
It seems like he gets a happy ending stark
contrast to almost every single other universe,
every episode that we've seen so far on What
If if you never read the marvel What If comics,
the whole idea is that they all have downer
ending's like it's all meant to be very twist
at the end very dark endings the showrunner
said she wanted this episode to feel a little
bit lighter in tone.
Even though we still got the ending it felt
like a overall kind of happy episode.
Like they have the record scratch moment the
end with the watcher's like wait what civil
wasn't clear in every single episode.
We been visiting different universes that
have all been based on different nexus events
different things going down differently in
the original main MCU timeline.
The sacred timeline of the other big difference
from the marvel What If comics, is that on
the What If series, everything is meant to
eventually crossover.
So even though they treated the episodes like
they were kind of one office they were meant
to eventually crossover.
So the multiverse avengers team is going to
be forming to face Ultron here with the infinity
stones and vision's body.
They'll be the main characters from most of
the other episodes.
So most of the big characters are all coming
back from each of the episodes like T'challa
starlord obviously party Thor here, the darker
version of Doctor strange everyone I'll call
him Doctor strange supreme that I know one
of the biggest questions that everyone had
the minute that Ultron came marching through
the portal from another universe with the
infinity stones in his army is where did he
come from.
Like what's his story and how do his infinity
stones from another universe work in alternate
universes of the marvel What If showrunner
AC Bradley admitted at a couple points in
previous episodes that she kind of messed
up a couple small things because the way they
produce the show.
Because the way they make all the Disney plus
series.
They kind of what have their multiverse crossover
cake and eat it to without going to deeper
technical on the rules of how everything works
is kind of the Wandavision situation.
If you remember during Wandavision.
There was all the craziness with the Mephisto
series obviously that did wind up going down.
But at the end of the day.
The showrunner on Wandavision claim she had
no idea who Mephisto was in.
Like she wasn't a big comic book person.
So there couple minor continuity errors are
just things that didn't completely add up
based on what you seen so far in the MCU.
That's usually where stuff like that comes
from.
Just like the writers not fully understanding
the marvel candidate for not being a long
time comic book readers so the idea with the
What If series is that it is supposed to be
canon to the MCU or the Marvel cinematic multiverse
like a live action version of Captain Carter
played by Hayley Atwell is supposed to show
up in the marvel movies in the future at some point
Anyone of these characters is fair game to
show up in live action that's the whole idea
they explained in the series.
Make all the jokes you want about how everything
is technically Canon now, because of the multiverse.
Thank you very much Loki and Sylvie, but because
what it is meant to be a multiverse crossover
series and they wanted Ultron to be the big
bad they needed to give him a really big power
up so they wanted him to be a version of Ultron
who in his reality did wind up getting vision's
body and all six infinity stones for those
of you asking who he sacrificed to get the
soul stone who would Ultron love theoretically
it would've been vision.
Like he was taking his body.
So he needed to kill him anyway.
So two birds with one stone, he sacrificed
him to get the soul stone, but they just transferred
his consciousness into his body.
Because when you're sacrificing someone for
the soul stone you don't have to destroy their body
They just have to die.
I also love the placement of the infinity
stones notice that the mind stone is still
in his forehead because he basically just
took vision's body.
So he didn't need to take the mind stone out
of his forehead way that thanos ripped it
out of his forehead.
This is also basically what his ultimate plan
would have been in the main MCU timeline had
he taken vision's body eventually he would've
learned about the other infinity stones and
then absorb them into himself as well.
Becoming a living infinity gauntlet, but because
they wanted this big multiverse crossover
and they wanted him that the infinity stones
they just kind of waves their hand it's that
you know what working to save these infinity
stones do work in alternate universes.
Because it have to in order for this big twist
to work.
So yes, it is kind of a continuity error per
the rules of the marvel universe and another
still lots of questions about Loki.
Like how do you can use his powers inside
the TVA to negate the power of the infinity
stones from a bunch of different timelines
and realities when it comes to the infinity
stones and the TVA on Loki there actually
a little bit more accurate on the Loki series
to marvel canon.
The way they explain how Kang created the
TVA is the created to be this little pocket
outside of the main timeline.
So that is not completely affected by every
little change to the main MCU timeline.
The sacred timeline in the marvel universe
one of the big rules is that the infinity
stones only work in the universe that they
came from.
So Tom Holland's MCU Peter Parker Spider-Man
got the infinity stones somehow in then jumped
into an alternate universe of the Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man movies his infinity gauntlet would
not work in Tobey Maguire's universe for those
you asking about Avengers endgame.
There a lot of people that are getting the
plot of avengers endgame a little bit wrong
when they talk about where there infinity
stones came from.
So the avengers stole the infinity stones
from their same timeline there always in the
same timeline with her going backwards and
forwards so all the infinity stones that Iron
Man is using when he snaps the infinity gauntlet
when whole snapped the infinity gauntlet to
bring everyone back all those infinity stones
are from the same timeline which is why they work
Even though they took them from different
points in that timeline when they go back in time
Like back the 1970s.
This is not an alternate universe.
It's the same universe same timeline.
Just an earlier point in the timeline they
don't treat it like an alternate universe.
So the end of avengers endgame with Captain
America's taking all the infinity stones back.
He's not taking them back to alternate universes.
He just taking them back to earlier points
in the timeline to clip the branches of the sacred timeline
so to speak.
If he hadn't of done that the TVA Kang would've
come back and done it for them that's why
he didn't get arrested by the TVA.
The reason why the infinity stones from anywhere
do not work inside the TVA no matter where
you bring them from.
Is because it's treated like a completely
separate pocket universe is all part of the
elegant way that Kang weaves the sacred timeline
together and keeps people from messing with
the TVA mostly obviously Loki and Sylvie mess
with the TVA.
But that was all part of his preordained plan.
Like he wanted things to play out that way
he wanted to find out if they were worthy
successor, so that's why he let them mess
with the TVA.
So when you're talking about the What If series
with this multiverse version of Ultron with
the infinity stones that is kind of a continuity
air.
But you could bend over backwards and say
well.
Because it's What If they wanted a version
of the infinity stones from an alternate reality
to work differently.
So even though I think that's being a little
too generous that would be the one way you
could explain that this works in is not a
continuity air really it doesn't bother me
that much because obviously the Naka start
doing this with infinity stones and all the
marvel movies and all the other marvel Disney
plus series like the just going to be talking
about these infinity stones this version of
Ultron on the What If series.
Now I know you are all asking because this
is meant to be canon to the marvel cinematic universe
What is this version of Ultron who's trying
to conquer the multiverse have to do with
the Kang multiverse war. Like obviously,
while this is all going on you have all these
versions of Kang running around trying to
destroy everyone else's universe.
Like I said the showrunner on the What If
series said that they had to start working
on this before they had written the Loki series,
so there are a couple inconsistencies with
the way they prefer to things like she said
that they would've talk more about nexus events
if they would've known the way the Loki series
is going to explain how this stuff works.
But because the multiverse is meant to be
infinite infinite universes.
The way I'm treating this is that this version
of Ultron is just in a different part of the
multiverse than where most of the Kang multiverse
war is playing out at the moment.
But I think will happen now though is that
was What If season to season three.
However many future seasons they do the show
you will start to see versions of Kang show
up during What If alternate universe versions
of the character incorporated into the plots of episodes
I think one of the reasons why Kang wasn't
feature during What If season one.
Is because they had to start the series before
Marvel had announced that Kang was going to
be the main villain of Antman three or before
they even did the Loki series of the What
If people did not know that Kang was going
to be a character in the MCU.
When they started working on the episodes.
But like I said, because of that multiverse
explainer that I gave earlier.
It still works.
Like it is meant to be a continuity air that
they don't address the Kang multiverse war.
So basically was going to happen in the final
two episodes is that though slowly bring together
this multiverse avengers team with the main
characters from all the other different episodes.
That's when all the trailer footage them teaming
up having their avengers assemble moment's
are from the way they explain it is that anybody
is fair game to come back during season two
for the one confirm character that will come
back during season two so far is Captain Carter
like the guardians of the multiversal multiverse
avengers team roster will be slightly different
during season 2.
And a lot of you are asking what happened
to the iron man on Sakaar episode.
They did say that one episode from season
one had to get pushed a season two.
Because of the virus shut down delays unless
episode eight is going to be that Iron Man
Sakaar episode that is probably the episode
that got pushed a season two.
And I think that that's where this version
of Gamora was going to come from Gamora wearing
Thanos his armor.
I think part of the idea is that a version
of Iron Man was going to be fighting a version
of Gamora inside the contest of champions
during that episode they haven't said anything
about who's the main villain of season two
is going to be.
But I know a lot of you are asking will they
do mutants in X-Men characters in season two.
I'm not expecting a bunch of those just because
there already working on the season two episodes.
Right now in they have not introduced any
like huge mainstream X-Men characters in the MCU yet.
That we know of so think you will start seeing
a bunch of mutants in X-Men characters on
the What If series, until we get at least
one or two movies with a bunch of X-Men characters,
but during season 2 will probably see some
eternals, some shang chi characters new characters
from Thor love and thunder Doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness.
Maybe other versions of Loki and Sylvie it.
Like I said yes we will probably see versions
of Kang show up in future seasons.
But if you have any questions about what's
going on in the final episodes.
Just let me know in the comments below and
I'll incorporate those in the my future bonus
videos my full What If episode 8 video will
post next Wednesday just like normal.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up a bunch
of big Netflix trailers this weekend to they're
doing their big comic on event make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss any those videos everyone click
here for my full marvel What If episode 7
video and click here for my brand-new eternals
trailer video for kit harington's black knight character
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you in the next video!